la peur ne me dirige pas elana lité non
plus la collaboration doit être basé sur
le respect et la confiance
battu lors de la primaire de la droite
pour la présidence de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines joséphine
coleman berger maire de plaisir n'a pas
mâché ses mots avant que ne soit ouvert
le scrutin un discours qui laissait
planer le doute d'une candidature de
dernière minute mais qui finalement se
voulait surtout une mise en garde un
dialogue et apaisement devront être les
maîtres mots de cette nouvelle
gouvernance et jean michel fourgous et
lui quelques instants plus tard n'a pas
manqué de lui répondre en insistant sur
son état d'esprit qu'il dit fédérateur
j'ai voulu prendre la parole pour
réaffirmer son engagement puisque vous
savez je m'occupe du projet territoire
et ce projet de territoire est justement
un socle fédérateur donc c'était pour
rappeler que c'était important que nous
allions dans ce sens
élu par 38 voix sur 74 possible le
nouveau président a été opposée lors du
vote au maire socialiste de magny les
hameaux bertrand guillon ce dernier en a
profité pour prôné le rassemblement je
sais d'ailleurs le désarroi d'un certain
nombre d'entre vous depuis plusieurs
semaines la preuve de ce conseil
communautaire
car ce besoin de coopération est réel et
partagée au delà d'une minorité ou une
majorité parmi les vice présidences
quatre ont été réservées pour les
communes dites minoritaires commune qui
annonceront dans les prochains jours si
elle accepte ou non cette main tendue
quant aux priorités de son mandat jean
michel fourgous souhaite miser sur les
atouts du territoire
on est aujourd'hui quand même une des
plates formes entrepreneuriales un peu
modèle en france donc il s'agit de la
conforter aussi bien pour les jeunes
chefs d'entreprise que les entreprises
déjà installées que pour les grands
groupes qui sont présents également
développé naître une plate forme
d'exemplarité aussi au niveau
universitaire il faut qu' on est un
modèle éducatif de l'enseignement
supérieur qui soit
qui nous place dans le fameux classement
de shanghai dans le top 20 est on en
train d'organiser bien sûr ces choses
reste que pour le moment l'heure est
aussi à la mobilisation entre menaces
sur l'avenir de la ligne 18 et
diminution des dotations financières de
l'état